first of all let me start by saying how
much I love to this movie was fantastic
but before I get into this I have to say
I effin loved Watchmen and I just I just
want to bring that up real fast um you
have a very small but an integral role
in Watchmen was there any can you talk a
little bit about why you wanted to be a
part of that show because it's so
amazing
honestly I Damon Lindelof was I gave him
his first job in television Nash Bridges
and he wrote me an O and I followed his
career you know he went on to write on
loss and Erica the co-executive producer
Ross and a lost and then the leftovers
and and then he wrote me a letter when
he was when he was prepping the Watchmen
and it was the most beautiful flattering
levar letter you could ever receive your
whole life and if you want an actor to
pay attention to you and come and meet
with you about a part just write them
this letter I can send you the template
because it works a hundred percent of
the time just tell them their how great
they are and the god of actors and all
that you like more and and they and I
saw I went to meet with Damon we talked
about it and he's you know he told me
what I was in for and I went oh my god
I'm in on the joke so let's do it
yeah you're fantastic in it that show is
amazing yeah jumping into this other
amazing project you're a part of what
was it like scripts like this don't come
along that often ever I mean there Ryan
script is amazing can you talk about
reading it for the first time and then
how much did you offer to pay to be in
it uh large large sums of money but
honestly honestly it's happened to me a
few times in my career where I got a
script Miami Vice was one of them I
wasn't called that when I got it where I
read it and I went oh well this is a
this is a winner this is a home run this
is
this is this is this is one of the best
piece of material I've ever read and I I
was I was gonna talk with Ryan Johnson
the next day and so I was trying to
think well what the hell am I gonna say
to him to convince him that I need to do
this movie and when we got on the phone
we talked about everything else but the
movie and the part and he said I'll see
you in Boston I said damn that that went
well um what was it like one of the
things about this film is that it has
such a great cast what is it like
filming with all those scenes where
everyone's together because the dialogue
is so delicious well I mean come on this
the the dialogue and the and this cast
is is we're all we are we're all actors
who have bodies of work you know and so
we know what it's like to play in an
orchestra you know and to do theater and
stuff like that and and when it's time
for our solo we'll get up and sing it
out Louise and when it's time to to
blend in with the strings we can do that
too you know so it was joyful and so
much fun one of what a blast I heard and
I could be wrong but I heard you did and
an improvised moment was when you hand
Anna the plate yeah
when you're talking did anyone know you
were going to do that or was it omelet
so talk a little bit about how you came
up with that because everyone laughs
well it's it's you know the moment is
about an entitled the entitled family
and he's talking about how his his
Hispanic nurse meaning Harlan thrombi
Hispanic nurse his part of the family
and yet he just casually leans over
reaches over in hands or his dirty plate
and I said what a what a what a great
metaphor for this moment and it it just
popped in my head and I did it and Bryan
Johnson thought it was pretty good so he
left it yeah it brings the house down um
thank you so much Congrats on everything
have a fantastic day